[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga Germany's
Conservative Party has a new leader on a
grid Crump Karin Bauer she takes over
the reins from Chancellor Angela Merkel
who was clearly rooting for her to win
the contest for the party leadership
formerly state premier of the Saarland
akk as she's often called edged out a
strong contender conservative corporate
lawyer Friedrich mattes
but despite being angling Michael's
favorite she faces the tough task of
uniting a divided party and heightening
her own political profile too many
voters she's an unknown quantity and
important European and state elections
are in the offing does on a great Crump
can power have what it will take not
only to do that but also to succeed her
mentor Angela Merkel as Chancellor
that's the question we posed on this
week's Rodrigo here are our guests it's
a pleasure to welcome Pascal
back to the program she's a
correspondent for the French magazine
Lacroix and she says I doubt that the
new team in Berlin will deliver a huge
boost for Europe and very glad to have
Derek Skelly with us once again he's a
correspondent for the Irish Times and he
says I believe
akk will have to make clear to Uncle
America land soon who is chef and who is
waitress in their relationship and
reestablished Germany as a source of
ideas and momentum for European
integration and finally it's a pleasure
to greet montalais Ming he works for the
daily journal data gosh Vigo and he says
akk is a conservative Catholic a
European she fought successful elections
House governing experience and knows her
own party well she could definitely be
the next Chancellor and multi lemming
let me start with you and ask you quite
simply why should the world care about a
change in the leadership of Germany's
conservative party a skeptical viewer
might say this is just internal party
politics the city who is is is the
strongest most powerful German party and
Germany I would say it is by and large
the fourth biggest economy in the world
and the strong powerhouse in Germany so
why shouldn't they care
they have to care who would be the next
Chancellor and by any chance the next
Chancellor is the new party leader of
the CDU so the the odds are high that
that Anika can pound power will be
possibly the new chancellor what that
means we're gonna come back to later on
in the program Derrick's Kelly certainly
our colleagues care 1,800 international
journalists were registered for that
Party conference at which on a great
Crump Karen Bower was confirmed as party
leader are they just in their political
bubble here in Berlin or is this in fact
an event of great momentum yes no I was
in hamburger was quite the bun fight not
everyone could get into the main hall no
I think this shows what people in
Germany don't often realize is how much
attention Germany now gets it started
during the euro crisis it's been
building Germany has become the
indispensable part of the European
puzzle it always was but I think granule
America with her slow deliberate style
trying to bring people along it just
made clear that whether you you can't
get a deal true without Germany and I
think that makes people here slightly
nervous when they realize how everyone
is watching but you saw it in Hamburg
everyone expects everyone is huge
expectations and there's been a lot of
vodka bar talk but a leaden period on
the farm actor we need new ideas we need
new momentum and the rest of Europe is
watching that may make certain Germans
nervous but I think they just need to
grow up and realize Germany is a big
power they might be comfortable leading
but at least leading by example and
coming up with some new ideas for Europe
humor opening statement said you don't
think this new team is going to deliver
a big boost for Europe the fact is that
a lot of people in France have been
looking toward this coalition government
for real movement on some of the reform
proposals that President McCaw of France
has made and they haven't gotten an
answer until now now on a great calm
Karen Bower is from a Western state of
Germany very close to the French border
at times it's even been part of France
in past history do you not think she is
going to act in a way instinctively
pro-european I think she's definitely
pro-european I mean she as you said she
has been Minister president in
in this region which is just opposite
Allison and Lauren she speaks perfect
French she has had a very very Pro
European policy imposing for example
that in schools you learn French the
language of the neighbor her program is
very Pro European I think it's it's not
so much a problem of her personality and
her politics it's the problem that it's
too late I mean we're going to have a
European election May Emmanuel Macomb
has been waiting for 18 months to get a
move an answer from Germany and now this
window which had been opened by the
arrival of a pro-european in France has
closed I think it's too late would you
both agree with that you both mentioned
European integration in your opening
statements as a potential plus on talk
about Europe the solution is right now
only a small part of it lies in Berlin
and Germany if we talk about Europe we
are watching the brexit ears and
watching the problems of him and on my
own
we are watching italy's government
consisting of left-wing and right-wing
populist parties East European countries
very nationalistic Scandinavian
countries facing right-wing populism as
well so Europe itself is in a very very
bad condition and I don't see how any
Chancellor of Germany if it's Merkel or
Anat kam can lower can solve this
problem even if you make deals with him
on Omicron about his reform plans and so
on and so on this is just a small
portion of what needs to happen in
Europe but you're saying well what can't
be done I think a new leader a new face
a fresh face can say create a positive
message in Germany I think they they
don't really have much trust in the
power of the message but she proved in
Hamburg being elected CDU leader the
power of the political speech
she got people behind them she motivated
people and she her entire speech was
very cleverly constructed around the
word mood courage so she could take that
and build rebuild a CD but take that and
to the European stage and say I'm a new
face I believe in momentum I believe
that the European Union of 27 has a
future and I believe in this project
and I'm not going to allow the debate to
be hijacked by populist because the
populist they're a tiny proportion the
non populist are the majority in Europe
and there is a considerable majority and
I think a European German Lieder they're
always damned if they do an homage they
don't you know think if Germany tries to
suggest something everyone else will say
oh this is Jeremy we're not going to be
bullied by Jeremy but you don't need to
come up with necessarily project but
just give a signal this is what Jerry's
prepared to do because in the euro
crisis all we've heard is what Germany
isn't prepared to do and I'm slightly
worried that the the European debate in
Germany has been slightly poisoned by oh
they just want to get into art they just
want to pick our pocket what's this
gonna cost Germany Germany is still a
fundamentally European country but they
haven't been you know honestly to renew
their vows and just rhetorically bring
bring a bit of courage in there let's
see what this new face as you put it
what's behind this new face and whether
in fact she is the leader who can help
Germany to renew its vows let's take a
look state Prime Minister CDU general
secretary and now the CDU party leader
on a great Crump Karen Bauer has had a
remarkable career she's considered a
political moderate and a team player she
was ugly miracles preferred candidate
but she is by no means a miracle clone
she comes from western Germany miracle
comes from the east cheese Catholic
miracle is Protestant and she has three
children miracle has none prompt Karen
Bauer differs with miracle and several
points of policy the new party leader
favors a tougher stand on immigration
she's opposed to same-sex marriage and
is considering reintroducing military
conscription
she says Germany should take a harder
line with Russia will Annegret prompt
Karen Bauer managed to set a new course
for the CDU
let's go when Angela Merkel took power
she was sometimes referred to as Cole's
girl because in fact the Chancellor
Helmut Kohl had been her mentor is on
the great compound bow anything more
than Mackel Reloaded is she really going
to take her party and potentially the
country in a different direction well
that's what she promised to do she said
I'm not a mini Merkel and not a clone
for Merkel and actually she's proved
that she is a solid politician and a
woman of her own
I mean she's directed she's she's been
leading the Tsar Salah this little state
and at the at the French border for a
long time she was Minister she she has
her own idea she's during the campaign
for the election as a president of the
city who she's she's also shown that her
ideas do diverge quite considerably from
the ideas of Angela Merkel on the on the
migrant issue on sort of social issues
like the marriage the gay marriage and
abortion
I mean she's not she's got to prove it
now and that's going to be very
important to now to separate to cut the
record to Angela Merkel and to show that
she's she can stand on her own feet
which I think everybody who's observed
her in the last years knows she can one
of the specters that has been hanging
over the Conservatives here in Germany
mother lemming has been the rise of the
far-right party the AFD uncle Merkel was
sometimes criticized from within her own
party for taking the CDU too far toward
the political center and alienating
voters on the right leaving them free
essentially to go to this further right
party would you expect under great Crump
Karin Bower to take the Conservatives
back toward a more conservative part of
the party spectrum I expect if it's
minimal portions I would be glad I think
that that the AFD will get between ten
and fifteen percent of the vote in the
East much more but that's the average
between ten and fifteen percent I don't
see any party leader in Germany in the
city who if it's really American
combo Orion spawned these were the three
candidates to really get them back into
the boat because well split them apart
but really all those voters back in the
conservative big tanks first thing was
European policy you could not compromise
about European integration in in in the
city who but the AFT were against
European integration and the second were
the refugee crisis so I can't see how
how in fact in substance any political
leader of the city who could bring them
back into the vote
darhk's Kelly you recently described in
an article Anika condo as a quote
risk-taker and deal maker are we then
looking at a real change in leadership
style compared to Chancellor Merkel and
if so where would you see those
characteristics coming into play
I think the fascinating thing about
angular America she spoke when she was a
child as a girl in school she would
spend the entire swimming lesson
standing on the edge of the diving board
and literally at the last moment she
would finally dive in she screw up her
courage and jump in and she did exactly
the same thing by giving up the CDU
leadership she waited for the last
possible moment she could do with
dignity and she did a loop in the air
and I drove into the water and got a
10-minute standing ovation that's
risk-taking but it was at the very last
moment that's one kind of risk-taking I
think Annegret cam Calvo has said we
need to be faster we need to be more
courageous we need to bring people with
us you know sooner rather than later I
mean Merkel frustrated many people she
joked about it at the party conference
who drove people her own staff crazy she
couldn't even come up with a slogan for
the party conference until a few days
beforehand you know and she ruled the
country this way possible you know am I
making a decision she wanted to see
everything okay every risk she had to
weigh everything up and that's that's
admirable but her calm camera said we
just need to be faster we kind of keep
people waiting like the biggest risk
you'd want to see her take right now and
what's the biggest deal you'd want to
see her make right at home I would be
very interested in seeing if she can cut
she can cut some slack for the various
wings of the party America she brought
the party to the center but many people
would say she neglected the right and
she did for many people the unforgivable
but she allowed a party to move in on
the far right and and people have always
said that it's the golden rule of turn
politics do not let anything come up on
the far right it'll be interesting to
see whether she chooses to be the person
to bring back in these conservator at
least make them an offer or whether she
will enable somebody somebody who has a
conservative profile to do that and
she'll say we're going to fight in
public but you have my blessing to do
this because we need to be more
inclusive as a party I think that hasn't
happened enough in the last year's so
she manages to do that that would be
quite something that the the CDU becomes
a catch-all party again also for annoyed
the vote Boogedy furious people because
there are a lot of them at the party
conference I I've been asking myself and
I wonder if you feel this way as well
Pascal what it means that the
Conservatives have chosen a woman for
the second time to lead their party and
whether that wouldn't seem to go in a
different direction from the idea that
they're returning to sort of their
conservative roots and base I mean it's
unfortunate that we have to ask
ourselves this question isn't it
nowadays it shows that the CDU has
become that metal has has managed to
modernize this party I mean you remember
when Matty was elected it was a
sensation a woman for the first time and
then and from the east that was also
something we mustn't forget we tend to
forget that she came from the East which
at the time was also incredible yeah
it's it's it's very it's I don't know
what to say about that it's just very
sad and we should take it as something
very normal and she can be she's a woman
but she'll have another political style
she might have she will have other
political ideas you put she'll stress
another direction but it shows that
German politics have accepted that women
can be in power and that's in this very
conservative quite patriarchal country
quite an event and well in the AFD to
some degree but let me ask you this
multi lemming a great can't calm can bow
announced that as party leader her first
actions would be focused on migration
and security but to be honest isn't the
debate on migration that has absolutely
split her party split the Conservatives
isn't it
very much about the past rather than the
present many people say Germany doesn't
have a migration crisis at the moment so
what exactly is it that you would expect
her to change and does she have the room
to maneuver to do it she's governing in
a grand coalition after all
and she governed in zahlen in this tiny
little state and and made some some
quite I wouldn't say spectacular but
different policies towards migrants or
refugees then in Berlin was done for
example miners that miners have to go
through in DNA check to see how old they
are if they are really miners or not
so she was quite stricter in in in in
the refugee policy than the rest of the
country there the states so there is a
different tone and I would agree that
there is no no refugee crisis in Germany
but we have a huge huge integration
crisis we have integrated I mean 1.2 or
1.4 million refugees since the fall of
2015 came into this country and it's
still a huge huge test to be solved
speaking of those deep divisions that
were provoked by the debate on migration
let's take a look at the other
contenders for the party leadership and
what that tells us about the current
political mood here in Germany this was
the moment of defeat mats who represents
the pro-business and conservative wings
of the party was defeated in the second
round of voting
the people of Germany expect the
government to exercise control over our
borders and over the people who come
here over the past few years we have not
done this another candidate
Ian's spawn the current Health Minister
opposes Chancellor Merkel's refugee
policy and takes a conservative stand on
many issues I want to see a Germany that
is modern and open-minded and shows
respect for traditional values homeland
and family the cpu's new general
secretary is Powell Tilak a former
leader of the cdu/csu youth organization
[Applause]
will these new people at the top finally
managed to resolve the deep divisions
within the CDU
Multi lemming former Chancellor Gearhart
Ritter says the CD you made a mistake
and they should have chosen Friedrich
mattes the corporate lawyer who was a
major contender would you agree with
that who would you have wanted to see
win this position I would say the
division in between the city who is not
a division in substance it's more a
division in personal likings there were
parts of it that like free thick mats
more than unlikely to come Kalin Bauer
but what is the real difference in
substance I can't see that any one of
these two would change the face of the
party in substance there will still be a
pro-european party you have to solve the
refugee crisis and so on and so on so
the basics will still be intact maybe
free thick mats would have been one of
these guys with self-made millionaire
image and so on and so on that will have
pleased a certain part of the party that
is now in let's say it is disappointed I
think I can problem but but I would
expect the disappointment to to fade
away in some weeks or months from now
Derek at the time of her election under
great Crom karen bauer talked about the
CDU being one of the quote last unicorns
in europe because it's a big tent mass
party regularly gets up to thirty
percent of the vote or more certainly
it's looking good in the polls right now
but it's not just a temporary bump do
you think yeah this is the question I
mean people in Germany tend to forget
it's a really rough world out there the
political world has changed sometimes I
think we're in a little stability bubble
here in Germany they bounce back from
the crisis quickly what's happening in
France what's happening in the UK the
world has changed the rhetoric has
changed political stylists changed there
are a lot of political bruisers out
there and I know many people friends of
mine really wanted to see footage merits
win their CDU memories because they said
who do you think will be able to roll
with the punches in the Oval Office
better from calvario you saw what
happened to Nancy Pelosi I mean Donald
Trump has a trouble with women leaders
generally and pretty firm might have
been able to give as good as he got so I
think some people will always wonder
what might have been that he is
rhetorically strong he knows the
corporate world
perhaps Donald Trump's the Donald
Trump's of this world would have more
respect for the type of self-made man
as well and that perhaps could have been
good for Germany but who knows we'll
never quite know how that would have
worked at Cusco your own country's
political system has seen significant
fragmentation over the past ten years or
so would you say Germany too is heading
in that direction and I have in mind a
quote from the New York Times that was
written at the time of this Party
conference of the CDU they wrote Marcos
looming retirement marks a deepening
crisis of the German political system
that threatens not just the future of
the country but of the European Union do
you see that kind of fragmentation here
and does it have that sort of very dire
potential for Europe well yes the
fragmentation has happened with the
birth of the IFJ
I mean who of the the rest the populist
party who would have expected for ten
years that the populist in Germany would
have such a big success
I mean it was the the only an end clave
in Europe the only country because of
its past because of its economic
successes which didn't have a populist
party now they have won and it's
threatening the agenda and and and of
all the other of all the other parties
and I think for Europe it's it's it's
bad news because we've been used to a
very strong Germany you know which was
the rock in the in the ocean which was
completely in uproar and and fragile
Germany is not good news for Europe and
France has been waiting the other
European countries have been waiting for
Germany to take decisions to be full of
energy again to be on board and they've
been we've been waiting for two years
now so the fragmentation of German
politics is not good for Europe let me
take us back to the woman whom under
great cramp Karin Bauer is succeeding as
party leader and potentially as
Chancellor and Dericks Kelly mentioned
it at the outset the fact that this is
an orderly and smooth transition party
leaders often do not leave they are
toppled that didn't
happen here Uncle America may have
waited but in fact she has handed over
the leadership in an orderly fashion
let's hear what she had to say as she
did so and now the time has come for us
to begin a new chapter at this moment I
am filled with one emotion in particular
and that is gratitude it was a great
pleasure for me to serve and it was an
honor thank you very much and as one of
you mentioned she got nearly 10 minutes
of applause following that statement so
questioned about all of you request for
a brief answer if you would will Angela
miracle really continued in office as
Chancellor until the end of her term
just gonna go around the circle pass go
well that stays in the stars she has
more chances with Ana great come come on
out you to get to 22 21 as with quickly
Schmitz who would probably have prepared
at some point some kind of push against
her sometimes said to be a risk to
separate the party leadership and the
chancellorship do you think that's the
case here it's not so much of a risk
because even though they are not alike
in the end and I think that carabaos
definitely not a clone of miracle but
they both have they get along with each
other very well so I expect her to stay
in power to transfer until 21 I wouldn't
be so sure I know many people in her
inner circle who say she's a woman of
her honor she promised voters last year
I will serve a full term but I think if
I'm going to come cause it says to her
look you're tired the party is on uneasy
if I can provide an honorable way for
you to go I need to cut the umbilical
cord and nothing personal perhaps after
the European elections or at the end of
this year if the part if she can go back
if mangle American go back to the party
and say well I wanted to serve a full
term but you've chosen otherwise I can
go and she can go with her head upright
I think she will take that option and
back to our title our title is
essentially asking the question will
under great Krum karen bauer being the
next german chancellor I'm gonna ask it
with a slightly different turn does she
have what it takes to renew German
leadership
in the meaningful ways that all of you
have mentioned Pesce she says she has
she says that you can't pretend to be
president of the party if you don't want
and if you don't feel that you have the
guts and the ability to be Chancellor
so let's believe her next Chancellor I I
think the you also had that she will be
the next Chancellor and she I think she
will be able to do yeah she won't be the
first German politician who got to the
top by being underestimated that's what
she's proven so far why shouldn't I
continue love of non-charismatic
politicians thank you very much to all
of you for being with us here on the
program and thanks to all of you for
tuning in and wish you happy holidays
see you in the new year
[Music]